you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played today May 28
2008 een on the white end Magnus Carlsen
rated 28 43 he's paired against Fabiano
Caruana rated 28 22 this was played at
Norway chess round 1 and win lose or
draw in this game certainly one to keep
a close eye on as that World Chess
Championship match approaches later this
year come November these the two that
will be competing so who if any would go
into that event with a psychological
edge I believe this would be this will
be the last game they play competitively
before that event so let's see what
happened we have a King pawn battle in
this one and whenever I see the bishops
opening this Bishop c4 I think okay like
just once something that's not heavy on
theory a quiet start to this one and
well plenty of their games have gone
down that path both players are you
might identify as grinders they do not
mind taking a tiny advantage and just
trying to convert that into the full
point let's see how this one develops we
have some prep work for a central
expansion that hits this does not hit as
that would leave f7 vulnerable dark
square bishop SAR quick to leave this
one and at the moment seven moves in a
slight development lead for white black
has a nice central pawn presence whether
or not you could say that these are
advantages for each side I don't know
these are the two that's really stick
out to me at the moment okay continuing
some space with a threat to kill the
bishop that's not happening c2 is now
opened Knight B to d7
he takes D C takes D both sides now
castled rook e8 to me rook e1 and rookie
a only after about ten moves or ten
minutes why would you maybe want to
hesitate with the move leg rook to e8 as
black well don't forget that this bishop
is bearing down at the black king
so however an indirect it may be f7 is
now a tiny bit more vulnerable without
the rook on f8 you know we don't have a
black bishop bearing down towards the
white king f2 is not nearly as sensitive
for white as f7 is for black so
continuing white looks to improve the
worst minor piece this second ranked 9th
awning up III g3 meanwhile black presses
on the Queen side grabbing some more
space a nice group of four pawns on the
5th rank and they look to move even
further the threat here is a 4 and once
a 4 is in that pond could be promoted to
a thorn on 83 it's just too deep in
White's camp so this has stopped
altogether this a b-pawn duo is
challenged a 4b 4c bab let's pause for a
moment 14 moves in structurally we have
some imbalances a passer for white and a
central pawn duo central pawn majority
14 black so how will this centre be
challenged you know as it well longer
its able to sit like this it's just
taking away so many good squares from
the white pieces let's see 93 Bishop d7
and this is Carlson's ideal d4 is a pawn
sacrifice
efore hits and where does the knight go
he's not going backwards you know that
would this pawn would embarrass that
night and where would he be going from D
to B 1 so that the b4 pawn could
embarrass him
no the idea is to jump in give up upon
the deep on
so that the d4 square is vacated for
what is now a masterful queen whites
down upon but has a fantastic Queen post
on d4 and it's not clear how exactly you
get rid of this animal I mean no dark
square Bishop around this Knight will
take three moves and it would be awkward
moves before you could even attempt to
challenge the Queen to do something
awkward like that run to v8 and then c6
okay a lot of stuff would happen if that
if that is attempted but how do you get
at the Queen it's not going to be the
bishop it's not going to be the rooks if
anything the Queen but even the Queen
finds it difficult to do that okay
continuing rook a to c1 rook d7 rookie
to d1 some square for the King now
flight square for black rook c5 no this
pawn could be captured but what's the
cost the wheels would be set into motion
d4 would hit the knight would have to
find a new square and maybe then d3 that
pawn would be getting way too invasive
the Queen stays put
rook c5 okay this may be the idea given
some time rook b5 rook before to pick up
the pawn the Queen goes nowhere rook a
five challenges this idea pair of rooks
are off a square for the White King now
and a slight improvement for the black
King okay as you know it's tough to
improve here four black pieces are all
on pretty good squares but tough to find
that you know tiny improvement for the
pieces maybe the King is a little bit
better placed off of the back rank there
are still some majors maybe one day
they're able to hit at that eighth rank
with check alright continuing rooks e1
and rook to c7 computer is a fan of
trying for Queen a6 here
looking to maybe sneak into e2 bit more
active would be the the black queen if
ever again queen takes b4 this pawn
could bolt d4 d3 that's not tried
instead rook c7 is giving the pawn back
in order to gain some activity the black
pieces will now becoming a bit more
active rooks are gone Queen takes b4
queen c1 Bishop to d1 and now trying to
take advantage of this pin what is the
White Queen do she gets right back to d4
this is still a fantastic square she's
up she's only going there she only went
there take out the pawn
she's returning now defending the bishop
making sure this pawn doesn't even have
the option to move forward Bishop e2
like it's out of the pin bishops are off
the knight recaptures the Queen has a
responsibility she's not inconvenienced
right defends b2 the night f2 everything
is glued together starting with that
queen who still cannot be challenged
material is balanced but White has now
two connected passers a be pawns and how
do you improve this Knight
let's see first we have a check King g1
queen c1 and the b-pawn gets rolling III
hits this is giving up a pawn in order
to grant the knight a square to work
with E for F takes e3 94 Queen takes d5
so what's the material count it's now
white at one point white was down upon
now is up to pawns black can you take
advantage of this pinned night let's see
Knight to d2 there are a couple
approaches here at the moment the knight
is cutting off the Queen's defense of d1
on this file you know as I'm taking a
quick glance at this position I think
okay the way to defend the knight is
Queen to D 3 and then Queen - E - that's
one way to do it but it was interesting
for me to see ok there's another
approach Queen f5 checking the game in
Queen to g4 so similar thing defending
along a diagonal but when you compare
eetu versus g4 I like the g4 post a
little bit better right it has a
responsibility of defending b4 maybe at
some stage there can be a check ok not
right now but it seems like she's a much
more flexible piece okay all of that
said in the end she ends up being forced
to e2 f5 trying to shoo the Queen away
of course he can't take but I just found
it
you know instinctually I thought oh you
check here and then go here but it's
interesting to just see the yeah the
different avenues and having the Queen
on g4 versus e2 okay in the end e - she
is she's on e - in in any event 94
looking at Knight c3 that's defended
taking away this intersection Square
from black Queen a 1 a 5 everything is
defended you know these last several
moves black pitch some material in order
to gain some activity White is now on
the backfoot
first rank pieces but everything is tied
together doesn't appear to be a way to
take advantage of this pin
so in the game it's 96 d2 is now
available for the Queen Knight c4 and
this is not the first time we've seen
the Queen on d4 any one of these four
centers squares are fantastic offering a
queen exchange at the same time Queen c1
King steps over Knight takes the III and
the Knights are off white is still ahead
materialized only now by a pawn but
these are too big pawns to passers King
F to Queen c2 white still has the
shelter and makes use of it first
inserting a check notice how many times
these central squares are being made use
of by the White Queen King on h2 black
wants to break down the structure to get
at the King this is blacks attempt to
try and hold this trying to pry at the
Kings home the G to h3 structure so f3
is secured with White's last move
another nice central square continuing
we have Queen a4 I like this sequence of
moves here Queen f7 check forcing the
King back and now Queen g6 looking to
pick up a couple pawns this hits Queen
takes B Queen takes H with check G with
check white is now up to ponds and it's
difficult for black to hold on again the
only hope is for some perpetual white
gives a check a little bit of reap
repeating there Queen h5 Queen g5 and
now gets rolling with the H pond given
some time you would like to see h6 or h5
h6 and then Queen g7 for me and if mate
is prevented that would mean the Queen's
are exchanged and if the Queen's are
exchanged the a pawn runs no stopping
the a pond
so Queen d6 in the game some more checks
thrown in there
h5 f3 that's a discovered check g3 f2
and now Queen to g6 if Queen takes Queen
pawn takes Queen width check and then
the king will be there in time to pick
up the pawn and this guy runs so what is
tried is King h8 and white gets the
Queen but black is there to produce a
new queen so now what do we have three
pawns to the good for team white well I
just has to make sure there's no
perpetual so wants to establish a strong
Queen post this is a good one
preventing any good check from the black
queen let's get a few more moves in here
Queen is there to defend the apron and
also defend the third-ranked so a check
and be thrown in here but the king could
then step up so for example Queen to e2
here there's King to g3 and once more
this Queen is a very good defender
against any ensuing checks by the black
queen having the Queen on the same color
Square as the King will do that quite
often defending against key checks by
the enemy Queen okay we don't have Queen
e2 here
Black centralizes a check on c7 King
steps up there is one check but after
King here there's not a good follow up
check
so queen 2e6 more checks another check
queen is once more around to help defend
the third-ranked squares and support a
six very instructive queen ending here
queen king no-good checks here same
color can't really get at the king queen
a-one and now a few more checks thrown
in by the white queen establishing
herself on d3 with cheque and now after
a seven this pawn is supported there is
a cheque that could be thrown in here or
here so let's say a check here after
king g3 once more queen on dark king on
dark there is no good follow up check by
the black queen after a seven in the
game move 77 this game is over Caruana
resigns there isn't a good follow up
here one threat that white has is to
give a check and push through producing
a second queen and you know for example
if queen a four this is one way that
white could go ahead and win give a
check King h6 another check I'm sorry
check here check on f6 and after King h7
we have a check like this if the King
steps up then its mate and if the King
goes back there's one key move Queen to
b7 there's only one check but after this
there's no good follow up check and
white is ready to promote next with
check towards this ending I thought is
there any fancy you know stalemate idea
I did come across one that I want to
share with you if this game continued
after a7 Queen a4 and check like this I
was thinking after a move like King h6
you give a check like that and then get
a queen this would be a draw
why feel free to pause the video okay
this is what black could do take on g4
King takes Queen stalemate and if you
don't take the Queen while black
eventually forces you to take the Queen
this would be stalemate anyhow just a
quick variation that I found interesting
towards the end of this one
it was very natural for me to want to
play to this back rank with check and
then just get a new queen supporting
that a8 square but in this situation it
would not be good because of this shot
on g4 anyhow this is as far as a win in
this one 77 moves between these two
before they fight next later this year
in November could have a quick look at
the tale the tape on this one I'm just
kind of zipping through we approach an
endgame pretty fast in this one
rook c7 giving back the pawn Caruana
that rook c7 move gives back upon in
order for some piece activity but there
wasn't any anything substantial you know
it was just a growing advantage for
Carlsen and these inaccuracies blunders
mistakes I don't know how much we could
really trust them for this particular
ending the reason I say this is because
for example this Queen this Queen h5
move was just a case of repeating moves
inserting up a quick check and this is
getting registered as a blunder can't
really identify that as our peg that as
a blunder in this case but the big thing
to take away from here is really just
the the growing advantage more so than
the the number of inaccuracies mistakes
and blunders for each side anyhow that's
all for this video feel free as usual to
leave any feedback to this one in the
comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you